[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis es
heute gibt es ein leckeres brot rezept
um fahrer werde ich einen spieler
schafft käse brot backen und darauf
freut sich ja schon sehr wichtig von
außen sieht es gar nicht mal so
spektakulär aus aber innen da hab ich so
ja das ist voll im grünen mit dem
schafkäse und das ist natürlich richtig
schön wird sich im prinzip braucht man
gar nichts weiter dazu alles vielleicht
mutter diese gemüse
mir wird es schon reichen aber man kann
es natürlich auch als beilage reicht zum
beispiel auch besitzt seitdem
ungünstiges mexiko hohl und brot ist ja
weil im prinzip ist einfach nicht diese
typische brotteig sondern erst 3
aufsteigt mit viel schöner lockeren teig
schmeckt sehr lecker wird eigentlich ist
einfach mal die zutaten unbe starten
gleich für das sport brauche ich 250
gramm je einen halben wissen hefe einen
teelöffel zucker allen esslöffel wasser
dreier etwas olivenöl 100 millimeter
mehr etwas pfeffer und einen halben
teelöffel salz und für die füllung
nämlich schafskäse davon brauche ich
etwa 100 gramm
ich habe ich 250 gramm ausgedrückten
tiefkühl spiele hardware ist aufgetaut
und zum bestreichen noch 1 1 nämlich
zuerst einmal die hefe und verrührt dem
wasser so kann nicht so gut auflösen
im staat gebe ich auch gleich zucker mit
rein wird das ganze mit einem kleinen
schnee beten oder mit einer gabel von
einem lasso und klettert dabei
die mischung gebe ich jetzt in eine
große schüssel und und weißmehl auch mit
dazu und die eier machen das ganze so
ein bisschen kuchen ähnlich also dass es
kein normaler bürozeiten da kommen wir
keine eier mit rein sondern eher so ein
herzhafter versteigert und herzhafter
kuchenteig mit hefe dann kommt dann in
wien steht dass so etwas
und jetzt kann ich den tag noch einmal
kneten
wir fahren
und da gebe ich jetzt etwa zwei
esslöffel olivenöl gebraten
[Musik]
und entstehen soll jetzt ein eher
ruhiger war hier betreibt aber bei
bedarf könnte noch etwas mit liebe als
ganz bösen sein sondern so dass ich ihm
später ebenso sind formen kann
wenn beträgt durfte jetzt betrachten
kneten und verbänden kneten bereits auf
etwa 35 grad erhitzt das heißt es
derzeit einfach jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen schneller aufgehen kann
derzeit ist wie gesagt etwas weicher als
normaler hefeteig in richtung buchen
teilt also frisch und den weg ich jetzt
mit etwas mehl ab und lasse etwa eine
stunde aufgeben
jetzt ist mein hefeteig aufgegangen sind
nämlich ein bisschen mehr auf die
arbeitsfläche damit der teig nicht klebt
und dennis auch wieder zusammengefallen
aber das ist gar nicht schlimm gebe ich
den tag hier drauf das sieht man auch
nicht schön weit ist müssen einfach
immer genug mehl zwischen fingern und
teig haben ansonsten klebt nämlich
ziemlich bedrohlich ihnen so leicht
eckig aus auf eine größe von etwa 40 mal
40 zentimeter darunter auch immer genug
gehen
ein bisschen knifflig aber sich später
andere leckeres brot
[Musik]
er braucht nicht mal unbedingt ausdruck
starb ihr könnt doch einfach mit den
fingern so ein bisschen zurecht sehen
und jetzt kommt da die füllung rein
heißt die hälfte des spiels erst mal die
hälfte vom käse wenn ich nehme 13
schafkäse der es schon fest und cremig
und ich finde das ganz gut ohne schönen
würzig im geschmack ist also ich mag
schafskäse ganz gerne dem buchmarkt auch
zu käse und aber ich konnte mich nicht
ob sie getötet zudem erwarten ganz gerne
abonnierst ein bisschen zu stark dass
ihre herrschaft und wenn ihr möchtet
könnt ihr an dieser stelle noch ein paar
chiliflocken zufügen da jetzt die kinder
heute bei dem fotos gar nicht mitessen
werden
dahinter sind großzügiger sein murat
verkraftet jetzt kommen da die zweite
hälfte drüber so fest wie ein buch
zusammen klappen wenn sie das erlebt ich
muss auch mal nicht schlimm
[Musik]
am besten nicht zu verantworten damit
zeigt sich jetzt nicht auf die
arbeitsfläche drückt jetzt kommt die
zweite hälfte braucht einfach alles
schön verteilen
[Musik]
importiert weiter macht kann ich schon
mal meine backform vettel davon in bad
wimsbach und hab mir 20 cm backform also
einen kampf in kuchenform jetzt rollt
hier den tag zusammen wie eine nuss doch
sozusagen
dadurch erhalten wir gleichen richtig
schöne optik setzt sich jetzt mit der
schnittkante nach ohne sind in die
backform
[Musik]
die backform setzt sich jetzt auf einen
treffer denn die bank mit der vorrede
seither ganz kleine löcher und damit
jetzt kein saft austritt von dem spieler
auch zum beispiel mache ich es lieber
hier drauf lag mit einem sauberen
geschirrtuch ab und lass uns noch mal
für etwa 30 minuten aufstehen jetzt
streicht sich das brot noch mit dem
verkehrs und dann kommt zu den backofen
bei 190 grad ober unterhitze für etwa 50
minuten
[Musik]
das büro das jetzt gebacken und ich hab
noch etwas abkühlen lassen damit ich es
einfach ausschneiden kannst und ich
finde zwar von außen richtig schön jetzt
kommt decken verteilt
und da kommt praktisch immer anders raus
also man kann jedes gleiche boot noch
mal machen das richtig schön saftig am
nächsten tag vielleicht noch um dann
kann man auch ein bisschen touristen
aber ich meine nicht so groß kann man
gleich erste school aus kuchen brot aber
aber also konsistenz ist kuchen ähnlich
deswegen so weich und saftig und abers
mitternacht hinaus variieren was auf
tour gewesen
wirklich zeit bleibt dann kommt jetzt
kein weiterer statement von bora denn er
ist es die brotlaibe auf und falls ihr
dieses leckere brot auch nach machen
wollt geht auch wenn ich - lok de dass
sie das perfekt für euch und falls es
nach macht daten hat um gerne einen
kommentar wie schmeckt haben duisburger
herz komisches brotes ohne irgendwas
braucht man alles mit schmitt zuvor auch
kohl vor allem mit dem ziel ihn stoppte
mich jetzt nur für design kann für mich
jetzt auch ziegen zu sein du musst ja es
war es zu massiven käse gerne aber ich
bin mir so das schafft ihr es ja beim
nächsten mal kann das für dich backen
und ich wünsche beiden viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]